I don't know what happens when you get
loud bad things happen when I get love
yeah what do you make loud noises just
court it's just like alright I can't
help them my bandwidth whoa-ho hello
there's a shark oh there's the shark I
forgot about it we need to go towards
that Islander or what's the deal
roughly towards it all those seagulls on
your thing I have learned it's actually
fairly easy to kill the seagulls and you
get the chicken wings from it and that's
that's maybe the way to live the chicken
wings yeah you get you get chicken wings
from seagulls yeah that doesn't really
check but alright yeah no no it tracks
ok cool
calm down calm down yeah tracks the word
checks checks had chicken checks doesn't
check this is nothing checks alright
we're about I hit this island we do not
have an anchor alright I want to I'm not
mark not live no a whole that's a little
rude a be whole I'll take from the aid
of the be alright anchored down I'm in
the water yeah yeah that's still a
problem shark come on yep pose
hey sir might I have a bite to eat
there's a big chest over here full of so
many food oh yeah for my food commodity
all right cool thank you and what it
takes somebody dude we are so heavily
stocked on food right now I preach a big
preach debt I don't even remember how to
do this it hasn't been that long we
played this why does it's it was like
two weeks ago or three weeks ago
Sally forever ago yeah yeah yeah I'm
looking for so who the hell drank all my
water and then pieced out I there was
one scoop there was one scoop in there
it was not oh no it doesn't redo in the
night was it at night it just did it I
just won no no no no
I won't know there's clearly no water in
there glug hang on wait all right you
got me
while we're here I'm gonna get some clay
so I can make some bowls so I can be a
super soup man Superman
just call me soup Bob I will oh yeah the
shark you keep it distracted I gotta go
down make sure it stays away that's all
I ask God Jesus Christ what the hell
that's oh my god it appeared in front of
me like a tell I don't know what I was
terrified legitimately that just holy
[ __ ] terrifying you kill me
I mean don't but [ __ ] calm down no that
that you don't understand like my
perspective that was the worst thing
that ever happened to any human are from
your perspective yes selfish man
that's name you don't need a room your
room is the entire thing yes yes yes
that's what we have the music does not
match the situations you know what I
mean weenie about you know I'm turn the
music off because it's just like it
doesn't gel with what I know really not
have any wood was that the situation we
worried yeah we always never have wood
someone's cheffing it up up there
burning all our wood for soup minutes
goddang and I need planks so bad well
alright we'll get on the road s did
anyone actually go on the silent
harvesting the trees well I'm going then
I don't know why that's usually Wade's
job he's the wood man I thought we had
trees to cut down with growing trees
they're not ready why did we go to the
island if you weren't gonna cut the
island
you guys want trees get bigger plot
crops get bigger what we need a bigger
boat before we can get beer plot crops
get bigger plot crop I'm telling this
shirt we're doing look kill the shark
dead yeah sharks not to speaking watch
funny cuz the shark still alive [ __ ]
yeah you two do not I've been the Inside
Man for another organization this whole
time you're telling me it was you the
whole time that's Wade's joke just wanna
be virtual respect his comedic genius
alright wait I apologize for insulting
your comedic genius
what of course I did I said it what you
mean that that was the first time I said
it was so sorry no no that's a little
that's a little much get out of here you
see go there even any [ __ ] for you to
eat you guys need to be more sharing and
caring shut up I'm going in the murder
of the shark
[Music]
[Laughter]
my life is permanently set to the
soundtrack of roller coaster tycoon the
roller I'm gonna drown oh my god what
you really don't want to do is drown I
can no yes oh if you really want to
avoid is grounding yeah I kind of
learned that the hard way the hard sexy
way no no no no it's like the no Lube
hard way you know what I mean what no
sorry
was this family-friendly do we not have
any guys I got some okay I go I don't
have any funny I don't have any
hey listen wait mark I don't know that's
weird all out yeah we are definitely
friends I know this but my whole as hot
as that is unfortunately no never say
that again never never again no hate
that I hate all that I'm not gonna do it
peer pressure does not work on me wait
okay listen wait I'm waiting it's wait
and yeah give me please put my own palm
sorry please I'm out of stuff is when
I'm really desperate mark and that's
what kiss your ass as much as I need to
uh-huh right now I'm not out of stuff so
just suck it fair fair you know what you
right you right you right
hey cover that oh [ __ ] this bird dead
this bird working dead milk oh did you
freaking get the bird I freaking got the
bird it's dude I'm gonna hold to pick up
the bird
feathers had some drumsticks baby right
cool house what's the status on the
shark didn't okay it's doing like shark
[ __ ] and it's really annoying
sounds like it alright I'm going back in
why do I have an hinge and an iron ingot
in my food box what is happening in this
world
it was perfectly framed through the
seaweeds to make it look extra scary
okay look relax
are you making fun of me man you making
fun how you look obviously you always do
that I would do that hundred percent of
the time my bro
that's that question you're right I'm
stupid I'm the dumb one here it's you my
fault I am aware I know I know
look guys I feel like I'm being bullied
okay good
glad we cleared that up here's palm
seeds I'll do that yeah I did it's gone
you you're welcome
I appreciate that you're welcome Thanks
okay do we need any more clay I forget
if we've been fighting about I could use
some clay I need bowls for my for my
yeah let me let me mix these together
and then work in progress
I got him what do you need him I need to
to make the circuit boards right here
yeah I just put them all in there and
here's a I'm gonna put some iron in this
one the rightmost one will eventually be
the metal chest Oh will that's good cool
we're out of planks oh my god
what oh no did we lose a sale shirt just
came up and swept up a sale flag not
your flag dude dude my flag frickin flag
I've had it up to here with you Bob I've
had it up to here
I will not understand your messaging
unless you show me I will I'm coming
down all right cool all right here holy
[ __ ] that's way higher yeah what what do
you want what do you want don't be mad
at wait it's not his phone I'm not mad
I'm short being sure no guys I can tell
I could hear the comment sections nah
stop are you okay please please mercy
mercy please are you okay
huh yes I'm fine anyway shall we get
this show on the road if you guys look
under crafting navigation the big sail
you need a receiver and an antenna the
sail
you mean the sail I would have if you
had been paying attention wait how do
you make a circuit board what do you
need to make a circuit board three of
them three what and three circuit boards
yeah we need to make the receiver and
the antenna all right well let me get
let me get us moving on our one sail
here you know mark you can want to
receiver an antenna on top of occasions
you know what I'm not even mad at you
I'm not even mad at you I even mad at
you but I will be but I will be you will
be mad at him I means I will be it's
future tense you just be mad whenever
you want that's not an impressive thing
to predict yeah but I will be I'm just
saying I'm gonna start making do I can't
remember why we need goo but I know we
need goo that's the one
no thing we might not have enough of is
perhaps copper I've got I've got tons of
copper ore and I just fired up for those
my four furnaces are gonna be working
overtime baby Marc is this blast and ass
with these furnaces I got us my impress
thank you thank you Jason's Christmas
don't worry I repaired it with the last
plank I had alright wait I'm gonna put
the goo in the copper in this rightmost
one that's where you'll find the very
brave putting me in charge of an antenna
receiver but I think it'll work where
did the GU I just collected go I
literally don't find you on the ground
here next oh oh that's yeah yeah yeah
it's uh I mean let me there we go
alright was okay Jesus Christ my GU my I
have seven right here for you that's
your left on the ground thank you this
might be everything we need yeah I got
some more scrap metal if you need it I
got I've been farming up planks just for
well I've been farming up plants to get
a replacement sale I'm gonna put it in
the right most fun again and you can
have how many planks you need
I like to I think okay perhaps you can
keep your place never mind
go ahead beer somewhere Bobby needs beer
don't even worry about your boy said not
to worry okay
what happened who are you why are you on
our boat I'm the man with the food oh
you're both mates age put it at the door
put some dinner and food man that's my
song baby oh wait I'm flute louder why
am i god so quiet
[Laughter]
I mean sorry I mean I appreciate your
efforts what we doing here you need me
to smell some stuff bro today we have a
receiver I don't know how they work my
son did someone take the planks out of
my smelters I don't think you can do
that thing they might have been used oh
yeah I guess if they just run on all
right I'm putting why what happened to
my smelters did they burn all the blanks
I put in them all right you know I'm
glad I stopped talking so you could
finish your mocking of me I I didn't
actually like it at all but you know I
like why are their planks everywhere
what's happening cuz I they were in my
inventory and or my inventory was full
as I was trying to form up I have so
many planks right now
good make another sale a rather big
receiver and intended down where would
where would you want those that aren't
in your way we literally have so much
space out here install this empty space
I'm too close to the edge cuz sharp yeah
yeah yeah here we go sure oh god I'm
thirsty apparently oh don't worry we
have a whole supply of water wired you
didn't say that will our batteries link
when you're thirsty mark thank God my
pain amuses you you are such a good
friend laughing at my misery it's
hilarious hilarious
our plank farm is really starting to rip
I got three trees here and I got enough
planks and whatnots to whoops
three thing going for trees some as the
whole thing just [ __ ] exploded
back in the 90s again I feel like that's
nitrous but I feel like that's very nice
more copper ingot mark yes I will put it
I think I actually have one no I do not
have covering it I'm gonna put coppers
copper is working I
what happened oh wait your job wait
topper I have dairy I don't have copper
and I'm putting scrap in the battery
guys why aren't we building a battery
whoa this is a cool thing wait it needs
a battery
I felt that I gotta kill that bird if
you see it oh Jesus No empty this beats
it's no no I mean there's some beats
your beats yeah Oh soup it's really good
food just gives you like - yeah the
Sharks in around still no I fell and it
was right there its teeth were all I saw
the damn it hell didn't fill up the
frickin water thing this thing works
yeah let's do it yeah what did you make
the batteries battery I see higher
higher what Wade get to building the
third floor come on yeah wave you
dum-dum come on Wade let's go bender
reference let's go that's I'm going I'm
being and being oh god my my in Tory's
full it's so full sorry bro I didn't
mean to roast you so hard dude it's okay
man I'm an easy target I get I'm trying
to build a stairs for your third story
here wait I'm not I'm unclear as to how
all I need nails freakin scrap is that
scrap metal god we need to then pop off
we need to pop off an island whoa
seas are getting choppy boys oh wow
mark help hey yeah who should I put the
sails dad what do we do I don't know
this isn't a thing that's ever happened
before
oh holy [ __ ] I'm trying to build you the
third story Wade but I'm really failing
here what do you need for it I'm trying
to construct it and I'm doing a bad job
of that this actually uses up the
batteries what to keep making battery oh
no no no no God what are you doing what
is your job bill bill build foundations
around the outside the net so they're
not the outermost thing Oh can they be
inside I was like oh oh that's that's
really handy actually that's extreme
credibly Andy I got you boo thanks boo
also this sea man
choppy I am when you need boo I just
need as much wood as you can give me
willed Wilden hey will good buddy will
known for years third story my friend
well thank you oh there you go there's
there's 31 I believe that should be
plenty for you you're welcome that's I'm
here for you will we got your back we'll
even were even fret for a moment don't
you worry every little thing is gonna be
all right will oh whoa buddy I think I
like that sound construction practice
there it's apparently too close we need
three antennas and they can't be close
to the receiver three
yeah what oh sure sure Wow
Laura you goofing on will ya shoppers
how wilt oh why didn't you think your
name make you forget a show at all
Missy's loud oceans last right when
you're right you're right and you are
correct sir Thank You Shan Shan what the
frick why is this wire running through
my [ __ ] here whoa what is this wire
we'll come on what is wire we go back so
far why would you do this well what's
the deal here we need three antennas and
they all have to be at least on level
two altitude it looks like yeah brick it
can't be too close to the receiver so
I've got to spread this [ __ ] out
well it sounds like we need a third
floor wrong altitude apparently it has
to be level three holy [ __ ] how much
wood do you need we'll for this we need
all the planks you have playing some
getting planks here I'll put them out no
I got playing on I'll put it in your
your chef thing for now that's thanks
you're welcome that's a mere four get
out of here you dead bird oh I murdered
you how do you like that but I'm not do
oh that's what it was how many degrees
removed from funny can I make jokes
[Laughter]
- antenna cost um God a circuit board
for scrapping a boat you cut out a
little bit there but I sort of got the
idea
[Laughter]
[Music]
discord can't handle me because he's so
funny right be contained all right wait
I built you a third storey house this as
this looking for you I need to go oh
this looks good man oh my god this is
this is a trial and I tell you what
better you better know where you're
trying to go when you're coming up these
stairs I do yes here let me uh case I
used up all that sweet sweet planks our
planks I missed so I put scrap somewhere
I oh I may have used a bunch of the
scrap for the construction I was just
doing scrap is hard to come by scrap
sleepy
which is weird cuz we got good ingots
I've got so many nice ink
you lose
how much scrap you boys are walking
between you I got to I have not enough
good news Wade
we got an island scrap in common baby
alright whenever I get some more clay
I'm gonna be able to make you [ __ ] so
much frickin soup I've got clay don't
even in clay you need clay if you have
like - clay oh my gosh more than that
bold right most rightmost table leg
right most up oh sorry bricks
sorry bricks clay ah I got your hopes up
and now they're dashed against the rocks
I can see it
I feel so bad I'm gonna paddle us to the
island I know breaks in the right-most
storage just to be there left I don't
know there probably is anchor like I
just built it just about to put it look
I'm here for you the guy here we go if I
get three more planks we can build one
of them permanent anchors what what
doesn't break every time you use it oh
actually we need some more ingots for
those shark that didn't work very well
it's so silent so yeah I just need five
more planks and then I can rip us off a
reusable anchor and I think my trees are
done growing someone oh there's trees on
the island clothes babies down murder
and my children here that's weird give
me your sweet sweet flesh I don't like
the Sun it will use it to construct my
home further are reusable anchor over
here on your sailing corner holy [ __ ]
its enormous massive big girthy
two by three foundations it needs to
have like a hole in the middle for the
okay that's a whole [ __ ] thing yeah
maybe temp.1 good for now no no I'm I'm
I'm building this boat okay
don't you even well if I'm not a wood no
you seem like you got it in hand help me
I typically say help me whenever I'm
comfortable yeah yeah that checks out
it's so sudden what the shirt
yeah the sharks being in there the band
by their I mean my my in me
in there in your insides what guys I
made a permanent anchor lookout
convenient and small it is I can't I'm
fine yeah mm-hmm I'm coming to look come
and take a peek thank you have an
enormous chunk of our time whenever we
so please yeah I'm gonna build a barrier
dream work teamwork dream work behold I
didn't insult you once I was only
supportive that entire time I feel like
that's definitely not true that was
exactly what happened and then you were
only that version of reality is actually
impartial Jones Wade just pick it don't
even listen to the facts just me or mark
yeah exactly that's what that's all you
do wait no stop I need Bob on my side
because whenever you guys are both
against me he's the scarier of the two
of you oh I'm terrifying
you're the pea who's like right it's
like cute you don't spell II but also
you're not you're not scared you try
trying to rub my belly try he'd see
what'll happen no I know you'll see no
you will see oh you'll see no you'll see
rub my belly rub me hi No rubba me try
no definitely not like what oh you'll
never guess what happens next
doctors hated eight markiplier they
literally use all of the water and all
of the things look there wasn't I just
filled that with like five
with five goups what sorry my good man
oops of water goo goo p-- the standard
unit of water ask any scientist he's not
what were you going to say she's not a
sign where are you going to refute his
credential he's not a scientist
Bob just extraordinaire would you like
some shark meats that's not really what
we had just decided but I do want the
shark me did you kill the shark I mean I
don't think he killed it here's some
clay Bob you need clay right yeah yeah
look at this guy wait really comes
through in the clutch I tell you what I
have been supplying you guys with wood
and metal if my furnaces with wood and
metal thank you sir where are you
getting are you pulling it out of the
chests out you're supplying yourself bro
Tyrone going downstairs and finding
bountiful no apparently I don't and I
apologize Alfred down can you go what is
it the bottom of the ocean oh there's
our history my food and thirst for both
empty so you're telling me that you're
dying yes I was under the water bragging
about how good I wasn't finding the
things I needed and then death yeah some
scientists huh hmm weird how smart they
don't die like the common pleb no in
fact they still die my hypothesis was
correct science all right well that
checks out this is raw egg on my Morag
on my face because i don't know how to
eat cuz I'm not a scientist so I just
splattered on my face I need everything
my dude I was weighing away on that clay
what I was already down here I saw you
slashing in you splashed in you cannot
say you were wagging fear in you're
sabotaging me I was already down here Oh
real mature
real mature real much I could have taken
any other raft with anyone who died on
the cruise ship that we survived
whatever like you are their raft you
came on my raft is how this week are on
wave threat aren't grateful okay that's
you're correct on that one but I'm not
happy about it not happy either no it's
like no scrap metal what happened to
Laura scrap I've got so many ingots can
I turn an ingot into a scrap metal
please that would be nice actually pity
all right I've got all three of our
antennas boilers they're not a lot of
harvestable scrap metal or on the island
either no this is kind of a drug at all
yeah it's kind of a dry island all right
we ready to move on I guess problem
all right we're kicking off we're out
here I dropped the good anchor just for
funsies hang on I never meant undo that
yeah it seems like my grand occasion
wait a minute
mark look I'm looking look look look how
strong I am okay watch me way the anchor
yeah Wow I shouldn't mess with you ya
know Wow all right that's pretty
incredible I just murdered her that
seagull so good that's great
his blood soaks into our potatoes as we
speak the way you say that makes me
hungry second chest from the right there
mark has all the metal and good side
you can count Wow what mark came from a
different conversation mathematical
wizardry there
I don't know where thank you for my
apologize I guess I'm just gonna get my
hook out and try and hook some planks
here we are desperate for [ __ ] yeah
every time we hit an island the planks
just disappear am i hallucinating or is
there a raft off to the left is am I am
i literally going planks well I mean
we'll get it we'll get it I'm swimming
to the ocean just searching for playing
yeah we're going the shark to come taste
my num num that's strange
wait you're sailing away from me if
there's like that's good to know that's
that's interesting do it so I don't do
it you know anyone also all my planks go
to burning I die burn them all all right
Wade you're our resident raft jumper who
are really the idiot that built this
raft is an idiot in there ed and so
we're gonna take their stuff is the raft
rubber and you're my idiot yeah get over
there three two one I'm the anchor hole
those tricky non-moving holes oceans
kind of get a little rough boys or makes
it even better trust me fifth
for what has been done while my back was
turned
I guess so much garbage that I don't
want
we need more storage well I think we
need to maybe streamline our storage a
little bit yeah that'll be yeah yeah
yeah I get you yeah I'm just I'm just a
firt because we've been running out of
these nets for a while cuz Wade keeps
missing the shark like a idiot
today on my walk yeah yeah but I mean
like before so I built the Nets back up
I just wanted to give away before we
played this before we did not play with
you you got it wasn't a Clinton well
we're we're work what're you on about
you absolute nutter this is the first
time you've ever played this game nude
we're not talking about maybe now the
net will be safe you crazy [ __ ]
all right wait no yeah you right yeah
you right you know it's big enough our
sonar is working well wait really come
take a look
wait you're not goofing we're actually
doing something
Oh okay so we need to go north northeast
we need to go 7201 bowie north northeast
Roger that captain north-northeast
heading confirmed all right you know
what direction to head north northeast
yes confirmed yeah oh wait I can see it
that's a big island there we go
now the nets are all protected sir
captain who's got me up in man me
honorary temporary captain are we
stopping on this island again didn't you
navigate a silence navigator what did
you not see the numbers on a banker
we're getting turned on we've been
turned
God now we're not going to be able to
get anything use the radar yes you look
at what it's punting at and then you go
that's clear as day do you know how to
use the radar snarky a crew member but
Wade yeah yes we are 1,200 meters away
from our objective which is not here
feet or miles or nards whatever the hell
that unit of measurement off on our
gloop you had an objective but you
didn't navigate us towards what kind of
/m burden navigator who are you did you
hear that in /am all right I'm gonna get
in the water and I'm gonna bang him yeah
back for second drooping these jerks
pissed easy mark fun No hey well I'm out
of the water so joke's on you he's
probably gonna have grow legs and come
out for mark oh that's that's fair you
you know you probably maintained that
I'm a hundred percent fine not even
worried about it uh-huh come at me you
shark [ __ ] I dare you I dare you oh my
god wait look at that way because he's
ashamed of them so you are a [ __ ]
little baby shark gear we'll never make
your father proud of you I wanna make up
never mind I can't hold that how do i
how do I deal with this how do I go from
stab stab stab nice dude alright nice I
got one stab in nice dude Frick has got
another bite in though man I'm close to
death I'm so close to get this one last
metal everything's great
yeah yeah I'm good yeah so good oh yeah
I'm captain and I say that this island
is cursed that strange I'm just gonna go
incus around the island here for a
moment
the only Kawai good sir Janka way what's
our heading
man we need to go right through the
island basically a little bit to the
right
on it boss we might bump this rock we
gotta go south ish into the island hang
on and rowing away all the rowing is
very effective look at that pretty
strong we're still weighing the rock all
right yeah we are I am grey all right
should I make another sail dude triple
sale baby
make sure your sails are adjusted
accordingly oh yeah yeah good good good
good thing in there oh yeah yeah you
could also say East East North it's
north east but more east right wait are
we going to that Island cause it's the
island that we're going to why do you
highly doubt it because we're still a
thousand of those due to my hickeys away
due to many [ __ ] Oh what you can come
check the Navigator whoa someone spiked
my water it was me you put some you put
some fun time juice in there I did juice
myself yeah I'm in a row cuz I just feel
like I want to contribute Lightspeed
over here I feel it is hammered it I
built the plank or hit on it you feel it
the force is with me and I am with the
force
[Laughter]
listen guys guys guys honey please you
know I live I live to make you guys
laugh I live okay guys he does when he
hates everything that's happening I'm
just I'm just over here like in my web
could just tears pouring out of my eyes
and you guys won't let up I can't
believe it it's far away man I captain
sir thank you I don't want to be captain
anymore
seems did not get me any respect I think
I'll have more respect if I'm all the
respect I've shown every captain I've
ever had uh feel bad for those captains
and why are you disrespecting my
captains aren't I your captain oh okay
there we go let's just let's just let
bygones be bygones and you know I'll
take me off the burner I'm roasted
enough and just let's get wait on the
stove let's just get let's roast him a
little bit okay I was not volunteering
but like I'll listen to the offer yeah
we had in agreement then we have agreed
do we disagree to eat Wade well I agreed
to listen listen to the possibility of
being eaten is that what you listen I'm
just gonna get some water and keep my
back turned and hope that you don't get
stabbed in it I would you why would you
why would you I mean I have an ax not a
knife so I couldn't even really stab you
if I wanted to that was Karma I hate
Instant Karma and I seem to always get
it Instant Karma is as bad as instant
coffee am i right dude Korean instant
coffee will make you change your entire
mind on coffee
do I have to yes you have to it's Korean
what does that mean you have to do I not
know about Korean thing dude yeah you
know my friends great you have to I
don't want to not sorry
I live in a place called the United
States of America thank you very much I
drink your water
you don't have to here but if it's
Korean you have to yeah you you would
have to why do you think every time like
something's trending ontwitter there's
nothing but k-pop gifts
yeah lien you have to you have to you
have to I don't want to you can't no no
no you you have to no that's funny okay
what do you do I'm not gonna do it it's
not me no it's not it's not me it's not
me looks like it looks like it's time
for a my scrim is over party you know
what I'm talking about I don't think
you're gonna do anything this well my
scrim is over I have to that I have no
choice only half after you then yeah I
still have to but I don't have to all
the way anyway hashtag mark markiplier
who's over party we're about 400 meter
feets away god it's so far four hundred
parsecs away when we get there better be
amazing
mmm I mean you can have hopes but like
keep them tempered you know tempered
like so far there's a game with like
three different islands and a boat and
one shark so like why should on this
game right now once we get there you
should talk it for now did I should talk
for nav well I should not other games
for bro what are you not [ __ ] on
them I'm just it's like a tinkle it's
more of a pee-pee it doesn't make it any
better feel worse yeah how do I put this
in a good way then oh it's like I'm
spitting on them you know that's even
worse that's not that's not acceptable
shove the mouth juice oh what's mouth
juice
[Music]
is that no there's a few more bodily
fluids just keep cycling through maybe
you'll get it I don't know semen that's
the end of that's concerning to me oh
whoa whoa whoa
something I see something some kind of
thing no it's it's more than an island
what the Frick is that Oh to what
international what is that like ultimate
raft yeah that's something legit
[Music]